Die zwei Sprechstunden. Hier ist Chaosradio 187.
Es emergiert gerade Corporate Social Responsibility. Also der Organismus lernt gerade, dass es für sein Fortbestehen sinnvoller sein kann.
Man nennt es Marketing. Es würde aber nicht drauf reinfallen. Das Problem ist nämlich Corporate Social Responsibility hin oder her. Das ist PR, das ist klar. Ein Großteil der Kommentare, die ich im Augenblick zu vielen Themen sehe, werden höchstwahrscheinlich von Firmen generiert im Internet, um bestimmte Public Responses zu erzeugen und zu simulieren. Ich finde das krass, wenn unsere Politiker sich treffen auf Klimakonferenzen und jeder einzelne Politiker möchte gerne ein Ziel erreichen, aber sie können es alle nicht, weil ihre jeweiligen Organisationen das verhindern.
Also würdet ihr sagen, dass im Prinzip die Firmen bzw. Lobbies der einzelnen Branchen im Prinzip eine Art Schwarmintelligenz sind, die aber asozial gegenüber anderen Intelligenzen handelt?
Gegenüber Menschen auf jeden Fall.
Gegenüber Menschen auf jeden Fall, ok.
Na klar, warum sollten Firmen sich sozial gegenüber Menschen verhalten, außer es bringt ihnen Vorteile bezogen auf die Baseline? Weil die Fitnessfunktion von Unternehmen ist natürlich letztendlich der Shareholder Value. Und es gibt ein Feedback dazu zum Wohlergehen der Menschheit, aber das ist relativ schwach. Das heißt, es ist völlig ok, wenn wir zum Beispiel jetzt alle Kohlenwasserstoffe, die wir in die Hand kriegen können, verbrennen, weil es ökonomisch Sinn macht, auch wenn es dazu führt, dass der Planet sich um 5 Grad erwärmt oder mehr. Und das hier aussieht wie bei Mad Max.
Aus evolutionärer Sicht eigentlich Schwachsinn.
Ja, aber das ist möglicherweise wie so ein Krebs. Evolution greift ja immer erst ab der nächsten Generation.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und wenn es keine gibt?
Das ist Ende.
Ja, bitte, bitte. Was? Ja, bitte, bitte, hat Spaß gemacht.
Gleichzeit.
Schmein Gott.
Eine Knappe haben wir noch.
Hier ist nämlich Chaosradio 187 mit Erdgeist und Joscha und ich bin Holger.
Und lade euch natürlich ein auch anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110, wie der Paul das eben gemacht hat.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch noch die ein oder andere kluge oder doofe Frage, die wir hier beantworten können. Können wir noch mal kurz zurück zu den BH-Vioristen gehen?
Der BH-Viorismus sagt, alles, was wir tun, ist eigentlich Verhalten.
Das ist erlernt und wir spulen da im Grunde ja irgendwie ein Programm ab, das man auch ohne weiteres umprogrammieren kann.
Haben die, haben die Recht oder haben die Unrecht?
Das Problem ist, dass die davon ausgehen, dass das Programm daraus besteht, dass es Reize mit Reaktionen wäscht. Und als Informatiker würde ich sagen, das funktioniert nicht. Ich brauche Hidden States, ich brauche inneren Struktur, die innere Zustände abbildet. Ich muss sowas wie ein Weltmodell zum Beispiel haben. Ich kann nicht einfach nur Reize der Welt aufnehmen und auf diese Reize direkt reagieren. Ich muss also bestimmte Konstruktionseinheiten annehmen, wenn ich das zum Funktionieren bringen will. Und das ist die Perspektive, die wir als Informatiker haben. Was sind die Funktionen, die wir einbauen müssen um so ein System, damit es überhaupt geht? Und da gucken die Psychologen gar nicht so sehr drauf, sondern die haben ja schon funktionierende Systeme vor sich oder Systeme mit charakteristischen Defekten. Die sind so ein bisschen wie ein Automechaniker, der sich weigert, unter die Haube zu gucken. Und der kann das auch gar nicht, weil damals gab es die Werkzeuge dafür nicht, um die Haube aufzumachen und zu verstehen, was darunter stattfindet. Und stattdessen, um rauszukriegen, was mit dem Auto nicht funktioniert, baut er so eine Art Hindernisparcours auf. Und da lässt er das Auto im Kreis fahren. Und dabei horcht er, was es für Geräusche macht und was für Geschwindigkeiten das hat und so. Und zum Schluss mixt er ein bestimmtes Additiv und gießt das in den Tank und hofft, dass das hilft. Und das ist im Prinzip das, was der Psychologe tun kann. Manchmal geht es gut.
Ich habe auch mal so einen Geschirrspülmaschinenreparierer, der genau das gemacht hat. Der kam zu mir nach Hause, hat gesagt, er mach mal an, wie aufschrauben ist eh nicht. Dann hat er wie so ein Indianer auf dem Fußboden auch gesessen, sich das angehört, wie es rumpelt und meinte, ah, ich hör schon.
Okay, das hat er aber, weil er es irgendwann in seinem Leben schon mal aufgeschraubt hat.
Ja, glaub schon.
Mach dir mal eine schöne Geschichte kaputt.
Ja, du hast doch eben auch hier.
Ja, also was wir machen wollen, wir wollen erst mal so ein primitives, mögliches Auto bauen, so einfach wie möglich. Und dann, wenn wir das hingekriegt haben, dann können wir mal gucken, wie funktionieren den Menschen. Wo finden wir denn da den Vergaser sozusagen und die Gangschaltung? Oder machen Menschen das ganz anders?
Was macht denn dieses primitive Auto denn?
Im Kreisfahren.
Ja, also was heißt das?
Was heißt das übersetzt?
Ein Bein kürzer als das andere. Na, das bedeutet zum Beispiel, dass es in der Lage ist, wenn man ihm zum Beispiel einen Körper gibt, sich dessen zu bedienen, so ähnlich wie ein Mensch das tut, vielleicht nicht ganz so geschickt, aber überhaupt.
Braucht das denn den Körper überhaupt?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, dass es auch in World of Warcraft ganz glücklich leben könnte, wenn diese Welt interessant genug ist. Also sagen wir vielleicht Minecraft, weil Minecraft ist schlau genug, dass man da drin Computer bauen kann. Aber das ist eine Sache, das müssen wir empirisch rauskriegen.
Vielleicht möchte es ja auch interagieren mit der stofflichen Reaktion.
Das ist, was ich ja vorhin meinte, dass ein Kind ja auch auf das emotionale Feedback, auf seine eigene physikonomische Gymnastik dort angewiesen ist, schaut, welche Aktionen irgendwie positives Feedback hervorrufen. Die Frage ist, ab wann man das dem einfach so hinmodellieren kann, weil wenn das Ziel unserer Forschung am Ende ist, irgendwas, was sich dann schon wie ein Mensch, wie ein Ping-Pong Ball, wie ein Gesprächspartner funktioniert, dann will man von ihm ja auch vielleicht bestimmte emotionale Interaktionen, die man so erwartet in der Kommunikation mit einem Menschen. Vielleicht muss man ihm das dann irgendwie noch als Add-on da am Ende mit beibringen, dass er sich nicht komplett wie ein gefühlloser Soziopath da herbewegt.
Egal, was du ihm sagst, der sagt, ne.
Ja, bloß ich, da kenn ich auch so Leute. Und da waren die Behaviouristen, sind ja dann, weißt du, du kannst ja dieses Programm da verändern, in dem die ihm einfach große Mengen Bonnen tüte und dann ist irgendwie so danach nicht mehr viel über und dann kreieren wir auch.
Naja, aber wir sehen ja, dass es mentale Repräsentationen gibt. Wir, nicht nur introspektiv, sondern wir operieren mit diesen Dingern. Es ist total schwer, sich eine Welt vorzustellen, in der es keine mentalen Repräsentationen gibt, also Dinge, die in unserem Geist stattfinden. Ich stelle mir das im Grunde genommen so vor, dass in unserer Systemgrenze, also der auch wie immer gearteten Grenze zwischen uns und unserer Umwelt, wir können zum Beispiel sagen, das könnte unsere Netzhaut sein, oder das könnte unsere Körperoberfläche sein, oder wir könnten sagen, es ist unser soziales Umfeld oder sowas, dass wir diese Grenze, die nehmen wir und überlegen, da kommt Information rein. Diese Information, das sind einfach Muster, das sind wahrnehmbare Unterschiede. Die Definition von Information ist im Grunde genommen wahrnehmbare Unterschiede. Und Bits, ein Bit ist die Maßeinheit für wahrnehmbaren Unterschiede. Und in diesen uns aufeinander einprasselnden Bits, die da über unsere Systemgrenze kommen, da findet unser Nervensystem eine Ordnung. Und auf der untersten Ebene dieser Ordnung stehen Perzepte, das sind so Regelmäßigkeiten der perceptuellen Wahrnehmung, zum Beispiel so was wie Kontraste, Konturen und irgendwelche Blobs und so. Und auf einer höheren Ebene setzt unser Nervensystem die zusammen, das kodiert die in Objekte zum Beispiel und Situationen und Prozesse. Und dann abstrahiert es diese Objekte in Klassen. Zum Beispiel wird dann aus diesem fälligen Ding mit dieser samtlichen Urfläche irgendwann so eine Katze. Und die Katze, die ist ein spezieller Fall von Tier, vielleicht von Haustier. Und irgendwann fangen wir an, die Haustiere stärker zu unterteilen, merken, dass manche Katzen bellen und manche Katzen miauen. Und dann unterteilen wir die Katzen in Katzen und Hunde. Und da auf die Art und Weise kriegen wir immer reichhaltigere Bilder von der Welt. Und die werden auch stark davon inspiriert, was andere Leute uns für Kategorien vorschlagen. Dann fangen wir vielleicht aktiv an, nach Unterschieden zwischen Katzen und Hunden zu suchen und so fort.
Das ist ein sehr spannender Punkt, der irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch nie aufhört. Weil eigentlich ja so eine Intelligenz immer in der Interaktion mit anderen Leuten auch existiert. Ich sammle selber nicht alles Wissen. Ich weiß nicht immer, wen ich fragen muss. Oder ich weiß vielleicht im Zweifel, wo ich nachlesen muss. Aber ich weiß auch, wenn ich bestimmte Stimuli brauche, auf eine nicht so einfach nur als Wissen nachzulesende Art und Weise, dann weiß ich auch, in wen ich mich da in diesem sozialen Kontext wenden muss. Und das ist sowieso vielleicht ein Ding, wenn Joscha meint, er braucht irgendjemanden, mit dem er Ping-Pong spielen kann, dann musst du wahrscheinlich erst diesem System auch mit diesem Ping-Pong geliefert haben, ihn mit Dingen überraschen, ihn dahin konditionieren. Was wahrscheinlich auch so ein Problem ist. Weil die Anzahl der Menschen, die so Computersysteme trainieren könnten, sind dann auch nur begrenzt verfügbar.
Du müsstest ja auch erst mal wissen, was das Computersystem überhaupt möchte.
Das kann ich ihm ja einbauen.
Stimmt, ich war schon bei autonomem... Was treibt dich denn immer so groß an? Das ist auch nur die Basics. Shelter und Fortpflanzen, ein bisschen was essen.
Ne, noch mehr. Ich glaube, du hast ja nicht nur physiologische Triebe, sondern auf der gleichen Ebene, genauso wichtig soziale und kognitive Triebe.
Weinst du, das ist so basales oder ist es antrainiert?
Ne, ich glaube, dass es nicht antrainiert ist. Es ist ja auch so, dass es deswegen interpersonale Varianzen gibt. Also ich kann ja gucken, dass es Persönlichkeitsunterschiede gibt, die auch bei den Big Five, also Offenheit und Freundlichkeit und neurotische Stabilität und diese Grundparameter, die man in der Psychologie einigermaßen bestimmen kann, gibt es, die sind zur Hälfte erblich. Das bedeutet, die sind eingestellt. Da müssen Mechanismen dahinter stehen. Und das sind, glaube ich, motivationale Mechanismen. Zum Beispiel sind Soziopathen, glaube ich, Leute, die einfach keinen sozialen Trieb haben. Das bedeutet, die kriegen keinen Lustsignal aus der Befriedigung von sozialen Trieben. Wenn die der Oma über die Straße helfen, erzeugt das bei denen keinen Lustsignal. Bei dir und mir erzeugt es aber eins. Wir fühlen uns spontan besser. Es gibt einen kleinen Kick. Und dieser kleine Kick ist ein positives Reinforcementsignal. Und die Evolution hat das in uns reingebaut. Das hat einen ganz knallharten evolutionären Nutzen. Du redest gerade den Behaviouristen nach dem Mund. Wenn ich den Behaviouristen, dann nicht den Soziobiologen.
Aber wobei, das liest du sich auch behaviouristisch verargumentieren.
Was ich im Unterschied zu den Behaviouristen meine, ist, dass ich mentale Zustände untersuchen kann. Ich kann darüber reden, was im Geist vorgeht. Ich muss nicht nur von Reiz und Reaktion reden. Das ist so der Unterschied. Ich will das nachbauen.
Kommen wir doch mal zum Nachbauen. Wie sieht es denn mit Nachbauten aus?
Was gibt es denn da Interessantes, abgesehen von Eliza und dem Schachtürken? Schachtürken. Schachtürke war ja so der erst dann so im Orakel angelehnte Maschine, die es so vorgetäuscht hat, man würde gegen einen Computerschach spielen. Und der war dann, um noch ein wenig orientalischen Charme damit rein zu tun, es ein bisschen geheimnisvoller zu machen, war er halt wie ein Türke verkleidet, oder was damals das Bild eines Türkens gewesen ist.
Computer hießen damals Roboter oder noch anders?
Roboter? Nee, das war irgendwie erst später. Asimov hat das doch erfunden in einem von seinem Roman?
Nee, nicht Asimov, das war... Nein.
Auch nicht?
Nein, der Tscheche war es.
Das ist doch gar nicht so alt mit den Robotern.
Nee, das Wort kommt von Roboter, von Arbeit im Slawischen. Und das war so eine Oper, die er geschrieben hat, Rostoms Universal Robots, so ein Androiden, die rumlaufen sollten. Aber dieses Konzept des Androiden, also des Maschinenmenschen, das gibt es schon seit der Antike. Wir hätten noch einen Anrufer mit einer Frage.
Namens Alex. Hallo, Alex. Du hast eine Frage, ne?
Ja. Also erst mal muss ich sagen, ich muss Fragen haben, denn ich kann nicht dazu sagen, weil das eine absolut abgefahrene Sendung mit dir gerade macht.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr fasziniert.
Absolut abgefahren. Also das mit den Organisationen, dass man da so denken kann mit den Filmen, ja, es ist so und es ist so. Deswegen kann ich einfach nur fragen, rein zu sagen, ja, ich muss das mal so reinschmeißen, sonst vergess ich nämlich alles, was ich sagen wollte. Und zwar, ich bin Papa von zwei Töchtern und hab mich ganz oft gefragt, wie das ist mit den Menschen oder mit den Kindern, wie die erzogen werden, ob das nur Umweltanflüsse sind oder nicht, oder ob sie als leeres Blatt Papier zur Welt kommen. Ich bin zum Schluss gekommen, dass sie als leeres Blatt Papier oder als weißes Blatt Papier zur Welt kommen. Allerdings ist die Struktur des Papiers immer unterschiedlich.
Das wäre die erste Welt. Also gleichsam handgeschöpft sozusagen.
Handgeschöpft oder maschinenglatt, strukturiert, ein bisschen gräulich, angegraut, wie auch immer. Die Struktur ist einfach unterschiedlich und das Papier kann man dann beschreiben mit Umwelteinflüssen. Erstens natürlich die Eltern, dann kommen alle nach und nach. Dann die zweite Anmerkung wäre, was hat das Ganze, diese künstliche Indigenz oder die Nachahmung des Lebens, zurzeit noch, mit der Fantasie des Menschen zu tun. Natürlich muss man auch wieder die Fantasie aus einer dröselnden Basis-Fantasie definieren. Und das Dritte, was ich dazu sagen wollte, ist, wenn man Gefühle erlebt, die du vorhin drüber gesprochen hast, kann man nicht die künstliche Illigenz so bauen, dass er auf bestimmte Reize mit einem bestimmten Programm reagiert. Das heißt z.B. man ist eingegeben, wenn er etwas mit blauen Augen sieht, was eine gewisse Nuance an Geruch hat und einen gewissen Tonfall, dass er dann sich zurück erinnert oder dass er dann ein Programm drin hat, dass er bei diesen Parametern sagen muss, ich liebe dich, ich finde dich gut. Ist das nicht der Ansatz, das so zu machen oder die Gefühle der Menschen entstehen noch? Das sind auch ganz viele zusammen gemixste Sachen.
Das, was du da erzählst, habe ich zwar in der Disco schon öfter gesehen, aber es macht mir ein bisschen Angst. Also wenn du wie so ein einfaches Beuteschema hast, hast du irgendwie blaue Augen und...
Nein, das ist ja nicht der geile Gönner. Ganz viele andere Parameter dazu. Oder jeder, den man erreichen will. Zu einer Liebe gehören ganz viele andere Parallele. Für diesen blauen Augen, das ist ja nur die Nacht. Aber so ein liebes Empfinden gönnen ja noch ganz viele andere. Aber ist das nicht der Ansatz, so was zu machen, nachzueinzünden, so eine Gefühle?
Na, wenn du irgendwie in der Historie siehst, wie sich irgendwie die Schönheitsideale von Menschen da über die Jahrhunderte verändert haben, dann glaube ich, das ist ganz einfach deutlich, dass solche Präferenzen in der Natur nicht vorgegeben sind, sondern anerzogen sind.
Da wäre ich total vorsichtig. Also zum Beispiel hat früher in meinem Weltbild die Vorstellung, dass wir alle bisexuell sind, super gut reingepasst. Dann habe ich praktisch auf die harte Tour lernen müssen, dass das nicht stimmt. Ich komme ja aus so einer Familie, wo meine Mutter eigentlich total dankbar gewesen wäre, wenn ich früh gewesen wäre. Aber das funktionierte irgendwie nicht.
Nein, also eine Schönheitsideale und eine sexuelle Präferenz im Geschlecht sind noch zwei unterschiedliche Dinge. Das ist wie damals eher die wohlgenähte Fahne.
Das ist sicherlich adaptiv.
Ich meine jetzt auch nicht, das ist nicht das Schönheitsideal. Eine gewisse Ausstrahlung muss ja vorhanden sein.
Das was du meinst, ist eher die Adaption, dass wir nämlich lernen, diesen Reiz mit diesem Gefühl zu verknüpfen.
Richtig, weil es ist ja so schon, dass mir zum Beispiel, mir persönlich, würde es schwerfallen, wenn wir... Ich rebe vielstens auf das Schönheitsideal, weil wir jetzt gerade sind. Es gehören noch ganz, ganz, ganz viele andere Parameter dazu. Aber als ersten Kontaktaufnahme, dass ich überhaupt mein Reiz wahr wird und ich Liebe empfinden könnte, dass ich bereit werde, diese Liebe zu finden könnte, es ist jetzt schwer, wenn eine grau, am ganzen Körper behaarte Frau auf mich zukommen würde.
Heutzutage triffst du die doch eh im Internet. Da siehst du das doch erst, nachdem du schon ihr Verscheiden bist.
Ja, du weißt doch, was ich meine, weißt du? Und da gehören schon gewisse Parameter dazu, dass ich erstmal bereit bin, sowas zu empfangen. Und dann muss sie natürlich auch das bestätigen, was ich mir vorstelle, also sie muss natürlich dann klug daherreden und auch spaßig sein und all sowas, bis ich dann irgendwann... Die Liebe, na die ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr...
Liebe ist ja auch schon eine sehr komplexe...
Das ist mir jetzt aber glaube ich ein bisschen zu platt, also schulde, aber das dann da so drauf zurückzuführen, dass du dann wie so Schlüsselreize ankonditionierst einfach auf die Weile und dann einfach schon meins verliebt zu sein, das ist nicht...
Nein, ich meine nicht, dass das Schlüsselreize... Aber irgendwas muss ich doch auslösen, wenn du hier dafür verliebt bist.
Ja, ja, das ist biochemische Prozesse, die ganz nützlich sind, um die Kinder dann irgendwie groß werden zu lassen gemeinsam, nachdem man irgendwie einfach nur dort wie Verkehr hatte. Genau, danach muss aber irgendwie noch ein Kit dazu kommen, der dazu führt, dass die Kinder großziehen. Aber das ist ja auch so ein biologisches Konstrukt, was ganz nützlich ist, weil meistens ist es nach sieben Jahren vorbei. Ja, da spreche ich ja gerade von. Das ist einfach auch so Hormonmix, der da irgendwie so sieht, ganz praktisch aus. So die Konturen da sehen so aus, als ob das Kind, was da rauskommt, ganz praktisch ist oder so und dann...
Ich finde diesen Ansatz gar nicht so schlecht. Ich finde es ganz gut, dass man losgeht und erstmal sagt, okay, wie weit kommen wir denn damit? Zum Beispiel, das, was du gerade vorgeschlagen hast, finde ich gar nicht so doof. Zu sagen, wir brauchen irgendwie einen Prozess, mit dem wir lernen, Sachen zusammenzufassen. Zum Beispiel, das ist eine Frau und das ist eine Frau, die aufgeladen ist mit bestimmten Erwartungen für mich. Also, wie komme ich denn dahin, dass ich überhaupt so ein Konzept von der Frau bilde aufgrund von bestimmten Merkmalen, die ich wahrnehme, zum Beispiel, dass sie sich so und so bewegt, dass sie so und so aussieht. Was bringt mich denn überhaupt dazu, die als Frau zu klassifizieren oder sogar als begehrenswerte Frau? Und dann eine ganz andere Frage, was ist denn dieses Gefühl eigentlich? Was wird dann da hervorgerufen? Ich würde schon versuchen, zu überlegen, was sind die Zutaten von all diesen Sachen? Ich würde versuchen, die zusammenzubauen. Ich würde dann feststellen, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und dann habe ich was gelernt.
Ich versuche mir das gerade wieder wissenschaftlich anzusehen, weil wir reden ja davon, dass wir das künstlich nachbauen wollen. Eigentlich wäre dann dieses echt fieses Experiment da mal zu gucken, ob wann man sich dann ernsthaft an diese eine KI, die da wächst, wie verliebt. Und dann hast du wieder eine Versuchsperson, die hier jetzt nicht abschalten. Ist schon hart, oder? Und am Ende ist dann auch vielleicht der Drang, das physisch auszuleben, dann auch nicht so richtig möglich. Weil dann müsstest du dann wieder hinter deine KI dann wieder plötzlich einen Roboter bauen, der dann da, obwohl da gibt's Puppen.
Wir hatten ja mal so eine Diskussion, da meinte ein Student, ich könnte mich doch nie in Roboter verlieben. Und dann meinte jemand das, naja, kommt drauf an, ob sie gut aussieht.
Also ich finde dieses Thema absolut abgefahren, wirklich. Und weil ich glaube schon, dass wir da schon sehr, ich hab da letztens auch irgendwas gesehen, was mich auch zum Teil vermockt hat, dass da irgendwer mit Gedanken im Rollstuhl gelenkt hat. Das ist echt abgefahren. Aber das kann man denke ich noch ableiten von den Prozessen, elektrochemischen Prozessen, die mir hin stattfinden, die man dann durch ganz, ganz sensible Wellenerde auch so ein Ding auf dem Kopf ableiten kann.
Diese bildgebenden Verfahren sind da jetzt schon so weit, dass man auch Koma-Patienten darauf konditionieren kann, in eine bestimmte Richtung zu denken, in andere Richtung, und dann wie ja nein Fragen zu beantworten, wenn da wenig Restkognitive.
Es ist Wahnsinn, was für Vortritte man macht, und wie schnell vor allen Dingen das geht. Also wirklich abgefahren. Deswegen bin ich auch gerade total fasziniert von dieser Sendung. Und muss da einfach irgendwas, nicht irgendwas, aber das dazu sagen, weil das auch mich wirklich völlig fasziniert. Und es ist schön auch wahrgenommen zu werden. Und da muss ich auch wahnsinnig. Also da bin ich total fasziniert, dass wir auch in der Welt leben und dass ich auch so etwas erleben darf, muss ich sagen.
Was ich total interessant finde, ist, dass deine Töchter dich so reingelegt haben, dass die als tabula rasa auf die Welt kamen. Ich wohne da auch im Prenzlauer Berg, wo es ganz schlimm ist, so richtig am Helmholtzplatz, so volle Kanne, lauter kleine Kinder, alle ungefähr gleich alt. Die werden auch alle gleichzeitig in die Pubertät kommen und dann sitze ich in Tempelhof und lach dich aus. Genau, und die werden dann auch alle gleichzeitig wegziehen. Danach wird es da aussehen wie heute in Charlottenburg oder in Tempelhof. Wülmersdorf. Die wir nach der Wende hingezogen sind und jetzt alle noch schnell ihre Kinder kriegen, bevor es aus ist. Naja, ich habe jetzt bei meinem Kind zum Beispiel gesehen, dass der wahnsinnig doll auf technische Sachen abfährt. Und dass ein anderes Kind, was genau gleich alt ist und was neben ihm sieht, wird davon völlig kalt gelassen. Dieses Kind ist wahnsinnig schwer von seinem iPad zu trennen. Und wenn ich mir das überlege, ich kann mich so gut da reinversetzen, ich hätte als Kind dafür getötet für ein iPad.
Ja, für Gameboy haben wir getötet. Früher, als wir noch für Gameboys getötet haben.
Genau, das werden wir mal unseren Kindern erzählen. Wir mussten für unsere Gameboys noch töten. Und die waren schwarz-weiß gezogen.
Und die Batterien waren nach ein paar Stunden leer.
Ja, das bleibt ja vielleicht so.
Alex, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Gute Nacht.
Die Frage, was da schon alles angelegt ist, das finde ich schon sehr spannend. Vor allen Dingen, was müssen wir denn alles anlegen, damit das Ding anfängt, sich sein Ding zu bauen? Und ich glaube, dazu gehört zum Beispiel Motivation. Das für mich war faszinierend, dass das kleine Beast alles genau wusste, was es wollte. Es wusste oft nicht, dass es das wollte. Aber es gab, und es wusste auch noch nicht, was der Unterschied ist. Wenn sie so zur Welt kommen, dann ist ja dieses Ding, entweder alles ist okay, dann sabern sie wirklich vor sich hin und kichern und so und machen nichtliche Geräusche. Oder alles ist scheiße und dann schreien sie. Und es gibt nichts dazwischen. Es gibt nur totales Glück oder totales Leid. Und womit dieses Glück und Leid verknüpft, ist das Lernen die Erst. Und dafür gibt es eine Reihe von parallelen Mechanismen. Zum Beispiel dieses Leid ist Hunger, dieses Leid ist Schmerz, dieses Leid ist zu kalt, dieses Leid ist langweilig. Und später gibt es dann auch verschiedene Responses, um einzufordern, jetzt möchte ich bitte mehr Unterhaltung haben oder jetzt möchte ich bitte was zu essen haben. Und trotzdem ist aber sowas wie Hunger und Interesse nach Neuigkeiten sowas auch schon eingebaut.
Das ist nicht vielleicht eher ein Reiz? Für dich ist es ein Reiz, für ihn ist es ein Response.
Er gibt eine Response auf den Reiz. Das heißt, er kriegt das interne Signal, dass da ein Bedarf besteht im System, auf irgendeiner Ebene. Und dass das dringlich ist und das das Systeme das überschrubst. Es geht dir nach außen, genau.
Wie kriegen wir da jetzt die Kurve wieder? Die künstliche Intelligenz?
Ganz einfach, wir nehmen Matthias ran.
Hallo Matthias. Hallo. Tag. Du hattest auch eine Frage zur künstlichen Intelligenz.
Mich beschäftigt die Frage, die menschliche Intelligenz zeichnet ja aus diese Fähigkeit des Vergessenes. Wir sammeln ja nicht Unmengen Wissen an, das wir vorsichtig halten, sondern das Gehirn ist ja in der Lage auch auszusortieren. Und das müsste ja eine künstliche Intelligenz, wenn sie dann wirklich von uns als Intelligenz wahrgenommen werden sollte, ja eigentlich auch können.
Der Trick heißt einfach Filtern. Du machst ja vorher, nachher, und Dinge, die du nicht mehr brauchst, werden auch in so neuronalen Netzen, die man nachprogrammiert, werden ja Synapsen auch genauso verstärkt, wie im Gehirn, die öfter benutzt werden. Und wenn irgendwas mal nicht mehr benutzt wird, dann wird das auch abgebaut. Also das wird ja schon versucht zu modellieren.
Es scheint auch so zu sein, dass wir eigentlich gar nicht so viel vergessen. Das Problem ist, wir kommen nun nicht mehr ran. Das ist einfach wie so ein Netz, wo das immer mehr Zeug drüber geschrieben wird und neue Verbindungen gemacht werden. Und irgendwann sind das so viele Verbindungen, dass wir nur die stärksten Verbindungen folgen können und dass wir große Schwierigkeiten hätten, an diese kleinen Sachen ranzukommen. Und dann merkt man, früher bei Hirnoperationen durfte man auch so tolle Sachen machen, dass man am offenen Kopf, weil die Leute sind ja bei den Hirn-OPs bei Bewusstsein, so Elektroden reinpikst und so ein bisschen reizt. Und wenn ich selber mal eine Hirnoperation hätte, möchte ich das unbedingt machen, damit das irgendeinen Sinn hat. Und dabei erinnern die Leute plötzlich an Sachen, die sie vergessen haben von früher. Und das ist total faszinierend, weil plötzlich diese Verbindungen verfolgt werden können, an die man normalerweise nicht rankommt, durch den richtigen Kontext. Also ich glaube nicht, dass unser Gehirn so gut ist in Vergessen. Unser Gehirn ist einfach so schlecht in Erinnern.
Also wenn du nach der Sendung nochmal 10 Minuten Zeit hast, können wir uns draußen gerne hinsetzen.
Wir haben ja auch einen kleinen chirurgischen Betrieb eingebaut.
Kennst du das mit dem Niesreiz bei Look Around You?
Kennst du Look Around You?
Das Bild hab ich jetzt den ganzen Tag immer...
Wir machen mal Nachrichten, danach geht's intelligent weiter hier bei uns. Ey Samma, der Typ da hinten, ist das nicht der Typ von der Fritz Music Tour?
Quatsch, der hat doch gar keinen Bus dabei.
Nee, der daneben, der mit dem Bus, wo Fritz Music Tours draufsteht. Ja, das könnte sein.
Von Rammstein über Seed bis zu die Ärzte.
Von Sido über Bushido bis zu Materia und den Kalkbrenners. Und erlebt eine Tour durch das Berliner Musikgeschehen von damals bis hier und jetzt.
Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Nur echt mit dem Typen mit dem Bus. Auf Wunsch auch als Walking-Tour. Dann nur echt mit dem Typen ohne Bus. Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Mehr dazu bei Fritz im Netz.
Unter Events. Und das war's mal.
Hier ist Chaosradio 187 mit Erdgeist, Joscha und Holger.
Es geht um künstliche Intelligenz und wir sind immer noch bei den Maschinen, also bei den mechanischen Dingern stehen.
Was ich da gerade total spannend fand, als der Joscha erzählte mit dem mit der Nadel da rein und so Regionen wieder reaktivieren. Wie im Gehirn ist denn da dieses Wissen so überhaupt abgespeichert? Also gibt's da irgendwie so die eine Region für, hier ist gerade mein Kochwissen und hier ist, keine Ahnung, soziale, emotionale Intelligenz? Nee, das ist einfach irgendwo und wird irgendwo hin konstruiert, wenn man sich erinnert. Da piekt man dann einfach nur wild rum und guckt, ah, da kommt mit dem raus.
Es gibt so verschiedene Dinge. Das eine ist, auf der untersten Ebene wird das, wir haben im Cortex alle möglichen Konzepte abgelegt und die sind miteinander verdrahtet mit bestimmten Arten von Grundrelationen, glaube ich. Und die sind aber nicht die ganze Zeit aktiv. Und wenn die aktiviert werden, dann werden die erst wirksam sozusagen.
Du sagst, entschuldige, du sagst, glaubst du.
Das heißt, gibt es valide Forschung dazu? Es gibt ganz viele valide Forschung dazu. Okay, weil du sagst, das glaubst du.
Da dachte ich, das machen das Wissenschaftler erst mal eine Hypothese, bis es widerlegt.
Ja, nee, ich wollte nur wissen, ob das jetzt eine Floskel war oder ob es tatsächlich nicht wirklich klar ist, sondern ob da... Das ist alles so eine Sache. Wenn jemand zum Beispiel heute über die Verdauung redet, dann würde er vernünftigerweise als Wissenschaftler auch sagen, glaubst du. Weil so alle zehn Jahre wandelt sich unsere Vorstellung davon, wozu das Cholesterin nun genau gut ist und ob das gut oder schlecht für uns ist. So gesehen ist es redlich, dass du glaubst, du sagst das. Und trotzdem haben wir eine ungefähre Vorstellung, in welche Richtung wir gucken müssen. Das ist auch nicht alles unbekannt, aber manche Sachen sind zu konstruktive Erfordernisse und andere sind biologische Erfordernisse. Und manche Sachen wissen wir noch nicht so genau, es könnte so oder so sein. Die zurzeit dominante Theorie geht davon aus, dass wir die Neuronen im Cortex sich in sozusagen Grundschaltkreise verschalten. Das sind die Cortical Columns. Von denen gibt es ziemlich viele und jede von denen enthält ungefähr so 50.000 Neuronen, die untereinander wie so ein Schaltkreis verschaltet sind. Und die bedecken diesen Cortex in Regionen und diese Regionen unterscheiden sich in der Zusammensetzung der beteiligten Neurontypen. Das ist relativ subtil, aber doch so deutlich, dass man mit dem Mikroskop das Gehirn in lauter funktionale Areale einteilen kann. Das hat zuerst ein Mann namens Brotmann gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob er es zuerst gemacht hat, aber zumindest hat er das so deutlich zuerst publiziert, dass es nach ihm benannt wurde. Diese Brotmannschen Areale sind seitdem nur ganz wenig revidiert worden mit neuerer Forschung. Also das gibt ziemlich viel Ähnlichkeit mit dieser physischen Landkarte des Cortex und funktionalen Geschichten, die dabei stattfinden.
Aber da sind ja nicht explizite Erinnerungen drin gespeichert, wie in einer Schublade, wo ich reingucke, und sage, ah, meine Führerscheinprüfung.
Ne, was da gespeichert ist, sind natürlich immer Informationen. Und Informationen über Konzepte bestehen aus relationalen Zusammenhängen. Das bedeutet, es werden Zusammenhänge gespeichert, wie einzelne Dinge miteinander verknüpfen. Vielleicht, wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Nehmen wir mal an, unser Gedächtnis ist so eine Art Teppich. Und die Erinnerungen, die einzelnen Objekte, an die wir uns erinnern können, sind Knoten in diesem Teppich. Und die Elemente, aus denen diese Erinnerungen bestehen, sind wiederum Knoten in diesem Teppich. Zum Beispiel erinnere ich mich an ein Gesicht von einer Frau. Und darin gab es diese blühen Augen, die waren aus dem Telefonat. Und die sind als Konzepte unter diesem anderen Konzept angeordnet, haben eine bestimmte räumliche Relation zueinander. Und das Ganze ist eingebettet in andere Konzepte, zum Beispiel in so ein Frauenkonzept und Dispoco-Konzept und alle möglichen anderen durch bestimmte Fadentypen. Das sind die Fäden, aus denen dieser Teppich gewebt ist. Dieser Teppich, der kann sozusagen aktiviert werden, indem irgendwas daran zupft. Wenn da was dran zupft, an dem Teppich, dann heben wir eine Menge von Knoten auf einmal raus. Das ist dann ein Zusammenhang. Und die gleichen Knoten können aber in einem anderen Zusammenhang was anderes bedeuten, je nachdem, was sonst noch so aktiv ist, weil andere Fäden damit da sind und die Fäden in alle Richtungen ziehen.
Ist das dann vielleicht eine Transferleistung, wenn man diese anderen Knoten benutzt, um ein bestimmtes Problem aus einem anderen Bereich zu lösen? Teils, teils. Ist das Kreativität, Fantasie, kann man das versuchen, da durch spontane Schälverschaltungen?
Es gibt Modelle von Kreativität, die dadurch funktionieren, dass man das Rauschen erhöht. Dadurch gibt es Schälverschaltungen und dann wird wiederum auf der anderen Seite gefiltert. Man guckt, welche von diesen verrauschten Sachen kann ich so zusammensetzen, dass sie doch wieder Sinn ergeben.
Das Saufen ist doch zu was, Juk.
Tatsächlich säuft unser Gehirn ja sozusagen die ganze Zeit. Also wenn wir uns diese Neuronen angucken, die sind ja total übel. Also so ein Neuron, das ist so ein Haufen Gallard und der hat eine ganz schlechte Signal-to-Noise-Ratio. Also das heißt, aus dem Rauschen kommt ein bisschen Signal raus und die verstärken das gegenseitig und helfen sich gegenseitig, um da irgendwas vorzubringen. Und selbst wenn wir unseren Neurotransmittern massiv rumschrauben durch Alkohol und Drogen und so weiter und so fort, versucht das System immer noch, da irgendwas Sinnvolles rauszukriegen. Und das hat das erstaunlich gut. Stimmt.
Okay, ich versuch dir dann die Brücke zu schlagen, dass wenn wir irgendwie ungefähr raushaben, wie so Wissen im Gehirn abgelegt ist, ob das vielleicht auch eine Strategie wäre, so Wissen zugreifbar, dann Algorithmen irgendwo hinsortieren zu lassen, wo es dann auf ähnliche Art und Weise wieder abrufbar ist und wie man das da tut.
Dazu müssen wir natürlich erst mal erforschen, was das überhaupt für Mechanismen sind. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wäre das nicht eine viel zu komplexe Aufgabe für den Anfang?
Ich weiß es nicht. Irgendwie müssen wir ja Wissen in diesem Computer... Warum unterhalten wir uns eigentlich mit anderen? Weil ich dich so gerne berichtige. Aber trotzdem, wenn das zu komplex ist, wie es im Gehirn passiert, wie speichert man denn überhaupt Wissen? Wie macht da Watson, dieser Computer, der da einen Jet-Buddy gewonnen hat, wie macht der, dass er irgendwie auf das Wissen da zugreifen kann? Oder ist es dann auch nur gefaked, indem er dann die wahrscheinlichste, keine Ahnung, Webseite in oder die Wikipedia-Seite, in dem das eventuell drinstehen könnte, dann da irgendwie hochrankt? Also gibt es da eine Wissensaufbereitung gerade in den Systemen, die versuchen wissen, irgendwo Persistent zu speichern? Oder ist es immer noch alles nur verschlagwortet und dann schnell genug nachgeguckt, damit es aussieht wie eine schlaue Antwort?
Na ja, das Ding ist, dass da in den Watson sind ja im Grunde genommen nur Buchstaben drin. Also Symbole. Und diese Symbole, man könnte argumentieren, die bedeuten ja im Grunde genommen nichts. Da ist so ein Haken dran, ich glaube sowas Bedeutung gibt es auch eigentlich gar nicht. Im strengen Sinne. Was es nur gibt, ist eine Kodierung. Also eine Kodierung über die Reize, die die Welt uns gibt. Wir fassen die so und so zusammen, aber das heißt nicht, dass wir jemals wissen können, ob das wirklich so ist, was wir da sehen. Wir haben auch solche Experimente gemacht, dass wir zum Beispiel unsere Fußballspiel-Roboter, die normalerweise die Welt durch eine Kamera und Bewegungs-Sensoren wahrnehmen und Druck-Sensoren, die haben wir aus der wirklichen Welt rausgenommen und haben die in eine Simulation gesteckt. Und in dieser Simulation haben die eine simulierte Welt bekommen mit simulierten Kamerabildern. Und die hatten die gleichen Fehler wie die echten Kamerabilder, damit wir die gleichen Bildverarbeitungs-Algorithmen machen konnten. Und es gab für den Robot überhaupt keine Chance festzustellen, ob der in einer Simulation in der wirklichen Welt ist. Weil die Simulation produzierte die gleichen Muster. Die Welt ist für das System ein Mustergenerator. Und dieses Lernen aus den Mustern ist der Weg, wie Menschen unser Wissen bekommen über die Welt. Also die beiden Mädchen, die kleinen Töchter, von denen wir gehört haben, die hatten natürlich eine Struktur. Also die hatten Motivation und Interesse, die Welt zu erkunden. Und die wussten aber nicht, in was für einer Welt die geboren werden und ob es in der Hunde und Katzen gibt und Gummibärchen. Das mussten die erst rausfinden. Und das bedeutet, dass sozusagen dieser Teppich, von dem ich vorhin geredet hab, der ist auf der einen Seite festgebunden an der Welt. Und die Welt zupft an diesem Teppich und zieht den in eine bestimmte Form. Und dieses assoziative Lernen, also das Weben durchziehen, dass es einfach der Teppich in die richtige Form gezogen wird, ist nur einer von vielen Mechanismen. Manche Muster kriegt man damit nicht hin. Manchmal muss man häkeln. Und ich glaube, für dieses Häkeln brauchen wir unser Bewusstsein. Also die Prozesse, die wir auch verbalisieren können. Das heißt, wir stecken da so eine Handvoll Nadeln rein, unsere Aufmerksamkeit. Und dann greifen wir uns ein paar Knoten raus und bringen die in eine neue Ordnung. Also wir ordnen diese Fäden anders an. Und wir können da auch nicht auf einmal allzu viele Sachen hochheben, dann fallen die Fäden nämlich runter. Also technisch ausgedrückt, es wäre super schwer eine Mechanik zu bauen, die in so ein Teppich reingreift. Und ganz viele Nadeln hat. Und auf definierte Weise da drin neue Muster machen kann, wenn ich davon Hunderte von Nadeln habe. Das geht nur mit einer Hand voll. Sonst wird die Mechanik zu kompliziert. Und so ganz einfach ausgedrückt. Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, weshalb wir auf einmal nur so wenig Sachen in der Aufmerksamkeit behalten können. Also sie zu Hause an den Nicht-Bildschirmen können sich das ja mal vorstellen. Auf dem Fensterbrett, mental vorgestellt, stehen jetzt Blumentöpfe. Da steht am Anfang nur einer. Dann stellen sie einen zweiten dazu, einen dritten, einen vierten und einen fünften. Das machen sie so lange, bis sie die Übersicht verlieren und anfangen Blumentöpfe zusammenzufassen. Und bei mir hört das so ungefähr bei sechs, sieben Blumentöpfen auf. Vielleicht gibt es Leute, die neun schaffen. Aber ich glaube, wenn jemand schafft, 20 zu machen, dann ist der so ein Rainman, dann ist der so ein Idiot Savant, der in bestimmte andere Verschaltungen sehr im Gehirn hat und dafür anderes nicht kann. Und das heißt, wir können wirklich nur so eine handvoll Elemente auf einmal in unserer mentalen Aufmerksamkeit halten, dann müssen wir zusammenfassen. Und was die Intelligenztests messen, ist im Grunde genommen, wie viele Fäden kann ich gleichzeitig hochhalten, bevor mir ein Faden runterfällt. Das ist kein besonderer Tugend, einfach nur Puzzle lösen.
Ist das deine besondere Art oder Gabe, mit solchen Metaphern solche Dinge zu erklären?
Oder ist das tatsächlich die Art und Weise, wie ihr sowas auch diskutiert, wenn ihr da vor allen Dingen auch interdisziplinärer angeht? Damit halt jeder weiß, worüber gesprochen wird. Das Ding ist, dass es diese Disziplin eigentlich gar nicht gibt. Die KI hat ja angefangen als so was super interdisziplinäres. Wenn man sich das mal anschaut, die Leute, die da hingekommen sind, das ist total cool. Da sind der Mac Carsey, der hatte sich so beschäftigt, was Berechnen überhaupt ist. Und in seinem Umfeld wurde dann die Programmiersprache Lisp erfunden. Der Nathaniel Rochester, der hat den ersten Assembler geschrieben. Also das erste Programm, mit dem man Maschinensprache programmieren konnte. Minsky, der ziemlich berühmt ist. Der Shannon, den wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben, der herausgekriegt hat, was Information ist oder zumindest eine wesentliche Interpretation davon. Die Informationstheorie. Denn der Selfridge, der maschinelle Wahrnehmung später gemacht hat. Der Ray Solomonoff, das war so ein... Jemand, der hat sich mit Informationskomplexität beschäftigt und hat sich dann mit statistischem und maschinen Lernen beschäftigt. Newell und Simon, die kamen eher aus der Psychologie. Lauter so Leute aus ganz vielen Feldern. Und die sind zusammengekommen und haben gesagt, lasst uns doch das mal bauen, das muss doch jetzt gehen, dass man diese neue Technik der Computer benutzt, um damit Denken nachzubilden. Und innerhalb von so einer Generation ist das pervertiert. Da hat sich das Ganze, so ein großer Bruch war glaube ich, in den 70ern, als der KI-Winter anfing, die KI vor allen Dingen auf Anwendungen konzentriert. Das heißt, wir haben dann angefangen, uns so auf logische Beweissysteme zu konstruieren und formale Sprachen und maschinelles Lernen und Dinge, die man nutzbringend einsetzen konnte. Das war immer total hilfreich und es war auch viel bescheidener und man hatte auch den Vorteil, dass man in das Grand Proposal Sachen reinschreiben konnte, die man zwei, drei Jahre später auch abliefern konnte. Das ist total gut, um das nächste Funding zu kriegen. Wenn man aber stattdessen sagt, meine Wissenschaft ist eigentlich eher philosophisch und ich mache diese Philosophie, weil ich als Programmierer ja weiß, dass ich nichts Komplexes mir ausdenken kann, ohne Fehler zu machen. Das lernt man so im ersten Semester. Ich weiß nicht mal, wie sortieren geht, bis ich es programmiert habe, weil alle Bugs, möglichen Bugs drin sind. Wie kann ich eine Theorie vom Denken mir als Philosophengrün den Lehnstuhl ausdenken, ohne dass ich das programmiere? Um Gottes Willen. Also muss ich es programmieren, aber das wird nicht morgen fertig sein. Das wird vielleicht in 50 Jahren fertig sein, vielleicht in 100 Jahren. Wir wissen nicht, in was für Flügigkeiten wir da noch reinrennen. Dafür kriegt man kein Funding. Und das führt dazu, dass...
Ach so, das ist ein Fusionsreaktor.
Außer es hört uns gerade durch Zufall irgendwie da draußen jemand mit. Wir bräuchten noch Geld.
Ich hab nun ein Konto in der Schweiz. Nein, bei mir.
Wir geben nachher die Kontonummer durch. Ne, übrigens braucht man auch inzwischen, wenn man überhaupt anfangen will, sich damit zu beschäftigen, gar nicht mehr so viel Funding, weil das Tolle ist, Computer kosten fast nichts mehr. So ein Computer kann unendlich viel mehr als ein Auto und der kostet so unendlich viel weniger. Das ist Wahnsinn, echt. Das ist der Hammer. Ich begeister mich immer wieder, wie wenig man einen Computer kriegt. Dann sagt jemand, da hast du diesen scheiß teuren Mac mit dem ganzen Speicher. Das kostet doch 200 Euro mehr. Dafür kriegst du bei deinem Auto nicht mal einen anders lackierten Rückspiegel. Mann, das ist der Hammer.
Andererseits kannst du einfach auch schon mit einem Rechner von vor zehn Jahren kannst du da schon alles mitmachen. Den kriegst du geschenkt heutzutage, weil hier kostet mehr Strom als der Rechner an sich.
Genau, also Computer sind wirklich echt kein Ding.
Du hast gerade gesagt, du brauchst kein Funding.
Du bist ja rüber im Clan. Nee, ich muss natürlich was essen. Ich muss meine Familie füttern. So Kleinigkeiten. Aber Computer sind nicht das Problem. Und natürlich, für manche Sachen wird man einen Großrechner brauchen. Aber unsere Schwierigkeiten, die wir in der KI haben, die sind im Allgemeinen nicht, weil unser Rechner nicht groß genug ist. Und durch die Amazon Cloud und Google und so weiter können wir inzwischen auch Sachen machen mit Rechnaufwand, die unglaublich sind. Da gab es zum Beispiel so im letzten Jahr eine Geschichte, die ist durchs Internet gegangen, weil Katzenbilder drin vorkamen. Und zwar haben ein paar Forscher von Google zusammen mit Forschern von Stanford, wir sind da in sehr großer räumlicher Nachbarschaft, deswegen geht das gut, ein System trainiert, YouTube-Videos anzugucken. Die haben nicht die ganzen Videos genommen, sondern die haben einfach zufällig Bilder aus YouTube ausgewählt. Also einfach mitten aus dem Clip rein, random, ohne sortieren. Zack, einfach so Frames rausgecuttet, 30 Millionen Stück. Und haben die in einen Supercomputer reingefüttert mit einem neuronalen Netz. Und das neuronalen Netz, das wusste am Anfang gar nichts. Das war nur als so eine Hierarchie verschaltet, so mit 15 Layern. Dann haben die das da drei Tage trainiert.
Warte, was heißt neuronales Netz?
Neuronales Netz ist so eine krude mathematische Abstraktion von dem, was Nerven tun. Man kann das verwenden, um zum Beispiel Sensormotorkopplung zu lernen oder Assoziativ zu lernen. Und dieses Ding hat durch ein bestimmtes assoziatives Lernverfahren. Du sagtest gerade, das wusste von nichts. Aber es hatte irgendwelche Prozeduren, die es doch schon gekannt haben oder implementiert haben, nach denen es lernt. Es hat versucht, darin Ordnung zu finden. Aber nicht nach irgendwelchen raffinierten Verhältnissen, sondern vor allen Dingen ein bisschen örtliche Nähe, zum Beispiel als Anfangskriterium. Und nach diesen drei Tagen hat das Ding mit einer ziemlich großen Sicherheit Katzenbilder erkennen können, unter anderem. Niemand hat ihm gesagt, es kommen Katzen in den Videos, wo er achte, besonders auf Katzen. Sondern es gab einfach nur genügend YouTube-Videos, wenn man ihm später ein Katzenvideo gezeigt hat, eine charakteristische Antwort kam. Also es hat sozusagen eine Art Großmutterneuron ausgebildet, für Katzen. Also ein spezielles Konzept hat sich von selbst daraus destilliert. Ohne, dass es wusste, dass es Katze ist. Also es konnte mit Katze nichts anfangen. Es ist auch viel ärmer als Menschen. Das coole ist, wenn man dieses Computerprogramm jetzt nehme, das er jetzt fertig trainiert, und ich würde dem YouTube-Videos zeigen, und es kommt eine Katze drin vor, dann leuchtet dann eine spezielle Lampe auf sozusagen. Ich könnte einfach sagen, hier ist jetzt die Katzenlampe und die leuchtet immer auf, wenn eine Katze kommt, egal wie die beleuchtet ist und in welcher Stelle im Bild. Das ist jetzt nicht hundert Prozent zuverlässig. Und das Ding weiß auch nicht wirklich was über Katzen, hat nie eine gestreichelt und so. Aber das coole ist, nur durch angucken von Frames, ohne Bedeutung, findet das das. Es hat nicht nur Katzen gefunden, sondern auch menschliche Umrisse und Fahrräder und alle möglichen anderen Gegenstände, die so vorkommen. Also ungefähr so 20.000 Objektkategorien haben sie getestet und davon hat es dann so 12 Prozent erkannt. Immerhin. Aber wenn man sich das überlegt, wie viele Daten das sind, ich habe mir überlegt, wie viel sieht denn mein Baby im halben Jahr? So im ersten halben Jahr, danach kann es vielleicht ungefähr genauso viel.
Das Auge ist ja auch vorher noch ein vorgeschalteter Computer, der auch für das Gehirn schon ziemlich viel vom Dekodieren der Gegend macht. Da kann ja schon ziemlich viel Physik, findet er im Auge statt, schon mal vorberechnen, wo Objekte demnächst sein würden, damit wird das Gehirn gar nicht behelligt. Also das ist irgendwie schon so ein vorgelagertes Teil des Gehirns eigentlich. Sodass dann selbst was noch an vielen Frames dort bei dem Auge ankommt, diese 25 Frames pro Sekunde, die werden dann schon noch runtergerechnet, dort irgendwie die wichtigsten Informationen rausgeholt und dann erst dem Gehirn zur Weiterverarbeitung gegeben.
Wie viele Frames kommen deinem Gehirn an?
Das kommen halt... Kann man so nicht sagen. Das wird halt schon vorher aufgearbeitet und sind dann keine Einzelframes mehr. Weil du ja irgendwie nicht so siehst. Also du glaubst denn nur, du würdest das ganze Bild erkennbar, dein Gehirn muss wieder zusammensetzt, aber du guckst ja immer einzeln und dann siehst du aus dem Augenwiegel schon, dass bestimmte Strukturen ist, wie da sitzt Holgi und dann gucke ich woanders hin, sehe immer noch, da müsste jetzt Holgi sitzen, wenn ich wieder zurück gucke und da sitzt kein Holgi mehr, dann bin ich erschrocken.
Was sollst du uns mal kurz überlegen? Also angenommen, wir können jetzt nicht genau rechnen und ich will jetzt auch nicht seriös sein, um ein Bild anzugucken, braucht man eigentlich mehrere Sekunden, wenn man vor null guckt, bis das Bild ankommt, weil wir setzen das jetzt so einmal ehrlich zusammen. Aber angenommen, wir hätten ein super schlaues Turbo-Baby, das ein Bild pro Sekunde schafft. Und das Baby ist sieben Stunden wach und macht die ganze Zeit nichts anderes, als auf Bilder zu starren. Das ist natürlich nicht gut.
Aber wenn es 30 Millionen Sekunden hat, das ja.
Dann würde es für diese 3600 mal sieben Stunden, für diese 30 Millionen Bilder, ich glaube über 1000 Tage brauchen. Ist das richtig? Ich glaube ja. Das heißt, unser System hat mehrere Größenordnungen, mehr Daten gekriegt, als ein Mensch verarbeiten könnte. Im halben Jahr, nachdem der Mensch wahrscheinlich besser klassifiziert als das System. Es finde ich aber trotzdem erstaunlich, dass das System das rausgekriegt hat, weil der Mensch, der kann ja gezielt lernen. Das Baby kann z.B. näher an die Katze rankrabbeln und kann Experimente mit ihr machen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Katze anfassen.
Du hast halt viel mehr Wege. Ich kann den Kopf bewegen und gucken, trennt sich die vom Hintergrund, wenn ich den Kopf bewege, ist die da weiter am Vordergrund und so was alles. Das heißt, das Baby braucht auch höchstwahrscheinlich gar nicht so lange, um Katze zu erkennen. Also um den Unterschied Katze zu erkennen. Ja, natürlich. Das sind halt viel bessere Daten. Und es kann gezielt bei den Stellen, wo es Unsicherheiten hat, Experimente machen, also gezielt explorieren. Aber das Ding ist, das ungezielte Expirieren, rein statistisch, kostet nichts mehr. Weil das ganze Internet liegt ja irgendwo bei Google rum. Und wenn wir wollen, können wir also mit Google reden und können sagen, lass uns doch mal zusammen ein paar Forschungssachen machen. Oder ich kann zu Google gehen oder so, wenn die mich nehmen wollen und mich KI machen lassen wollen. Und dann können wir da diese Daten durchforsten und nach Regelmäßigkeiten suchen. Und da die Computer so ziemlich schnell sind inzwischen, ist das ja kein Problem. Die werden ohne Ermüdung diese Daten durchmustern und möglicherweise ähnliche Codierungen über diese Daten finden, wie wir finden, wenn wir durch die Welt gehen. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, dass natürlich es viel spannender ist, ein System zu bauen, das so wie wir durch die Welt geht und es dann viel weniger Daten braucht. Weil ich möchte ja auch verstehen, wie wir funktionieren.
Und vor allen Dingen würde das System, was du dann bei Google laufen lässt, nichts aus den Unterschieden machen, die es festgestellt hat, oder?
Ja, Google würde dann bestimmt was draus machen.
Ich weiß doch, was sie filtern werden. Vielleicht gibt es noch einen Betalecount, wo du deine Katzenbilder sehen darfst, nur noch für Geld oder so.
Wir haben es jetzt noch nicht geschafft, Google Geld zu geben. Ich hab seit mindestens zehn Jahren darauf gewartet, dass ich Google Geld zahlen darf.
Ich kaufe dir doch ein Nexus.
Das geht aber auch nicht direkt zu Google, das Geld. Ich glaube, Google bezahlt ja die Hardware-Firmen dafür, dass das Google Zeug draufkommt.
Das ist ein Google Wallet-Account.
Du könntest... Du könntest doch...
Also ich würde für Gmail gutes Geld bezahlen. Achso, ich dachte, sonst hätten wir das irgendwie anders machen können.
Du schaltest Werbung in deinem Sinne, dann kommt Google Geld an.
Egal.
Was die Maschine, die du dann bei Google da schreiben würdest, oder was der Computer da bei Google machen würde, würde halt einen Unterschied feststellen. Der Unterschied wäre möglicherweise Katze, aber das würde sich nicht in irgendwie ein Verhalten oder eine Handlung oder einen Ethos übersetzen. Das müsstest du aber reinschreiben.
Ja, das widerspricht sich aber nicht. Vielleicht können wir ja zusätzlich ähnliche Lernverfahren dafür anwenden. Aber es ist auch klar, das ist nur ein reines visuelles Paradigma, was keine Bewegungen kann und das ist nicht verknüpft mit irgendwelchen Handlungs- oder sozialen Zusammenhängen und so fort, sondern nur ein ganz primitives Modell von einem winzigen Teil des Gehirns.
Kann man einem Computer beibringen, dass er jetzt mal gefälligst forschen geht? Also du bekommst das Bild und sag mal, was du jetzt damit machen würdest. Dann muss der Computer dann irgendwie einen Antrieb haben, um das rausfinden zu wollen, aber das kann man ihm ja irgendwie kodifizieren als ein seiner Antriebe und Forscherdrang. Und dann braucht er eigentlich nur noch die Möglichkeit, da wie, ja, zu interagieren.
Ich hab eine ganze Weile überlegt, wie könnte man denn Forscherdrang einbauen? Und die beste Idee, die ich bis jetzt dazu gefunden hab, die ist von Dietrich Dörner, so einem theoretischen Psychologen in Bamberg, dem einzigen Einhaber eines Lehrschluss für theoretische Psychologie, soweit ich informiert bin. Der ist allerdings inzwischen immer irritiert. Und der hat in der Zeit des Behaviourismus publiziert, was dazu führte, dass die meisten mit seinem Zeug nichts anfangen konnten. Und er hat dann aufgegeben, für die Psychologen zu schreiben und hat dann so geschrieben, dass normale Leute das verstehen, aber die Psychologen nicht mehr. Und, äh, meine Dissertation hat zum großen Teil davon gehandelt, das wieder in Wissenschaft zu übersetzen. Also es ist nicht unwissenschaftlich, was er da macht, es verwendet man einfach nicht die Sprache von den neuen Wissenschaften, also Cognitive Science und Cognitive Modellierung, Cognitive Architekturen, KI-Architekturen, die es eigentlich hätte übersetzt werden müssen, damit die Leute damit anfangen können. Ja, ich finde das total klasse. Der hat sich gesagt, irgendwann ist doch scheiß egal, was die Leute gerade für Zeug machen. Das meiste davon, was die Leute jetzt machen, da wird in 50 Jahren keine Sauberin nachgrähen. Lass uns lieber irgendwas machen, mit dem ich in 100 Jahren total berühmt werde.
Das ist eigentlich ein sehr guter Ansatz. Das hätte uns mal früher einfallen sollen.
Es nützt uns aber nichts. Wir müssen jetzt Brötchen kaufen.
Deswegen wollten wir ja dann nachher die Telefonnummer noch mal rausgeben, wo die Fanda...
Die Klare mit den kognitiven Trieben. Ich habe es schon erwähnt, dass ich glaube, dass neben den physiologischen Trieben, also sowas wie Hunger und Durst, und ich glaube Hunger und Durst erschlägt es nicht. Das sind Hunderte, die da Untertriebe aus dem Hunger und Durst bestehen, allein. Und Wärme und Kälte und Schmerzvermeidung und all diese Dinge. Dann gibt es Soziale. Dazu gehört es zum Beispiel, dass man von anderen Akzeptanzsignale bekommt und dass man auch von sich selber Akzeptanzsignale bekommt. Das ist auch wichtig, dass man sich auch dann korrekt sozial verhelfen, wenn keiner zuguckt. Das ist nicht dasselbe Verhalten wie das, was man der Öffentlichkeit zeigt. Aber trotzdem gibt es Dinge, die ich nicht tun würde, weil ich mir sonst nicht mehr in die Augen gucken könnte.
Das ist, wenn du nachts bei der roten Ampel stehen bleibst, wenn keiner da ist?
Es gibt Leute, die machen das. Ich mach das nicht, aber Leute, das habe ich gehört, das soll es geben. Aber da gibt es halt auch interessante Persönlichkeitstypen, die sich da unterscheiden an genau dieser Stelle, ob sie über die Straße gehen, wenn keiner zuguckt. Das Katastrophalste an dieser Sendung ist eigentlich, dass sie genau jetzt zu Ende ist. Ich wollte gerade das Rätsel lösen, wie KI geht. Okay, nächstes Mal. Das war Chaosradio 187, es gibt künstliche Intelligenz.
Ich habe den dringenden Verdacht, dass es noch ein Chaosradio zum Thema künstliche Intelligenz geben wird. Ich habe außerdem den Verdacht, dass es noch ein Chaosradio zum Thema künstliche Intelligenz geben wird.
Ich habe den Verdacht, wir sind gerade in der Schleife gelandet. Vielen Dank, Erdreiß, vielen Dank, Joscha.
Danke Holgi.
Es war schön hier.
Ja, dann kommen doch gefälligst einfach mal wieder. Das war das Chaosradio für diesen Monat.
Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es am letzten Donnerstag im März.